brought to you by Final Fantasy 15
available on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
November 29th final fantasy 15 is at
this week so for today's sponsored
episode I thought we talked about some
of the super cool things you can get up
to in the game so let's tuck into that
speaking of tucking in Final Fantasy 15
is really big on food so much so that in
the day one update which is filled with
things that Square Enix wanted to fit in
before the game was released you can
find both a culinary discovery gallery
and a wider array of recipes not only
just Final Fantasy 15 lets you feed your
crew of Bros a hearty campfire meal
after a long day of killing [ __ ] Square
Enix so clearly hides some kind of food
with the darkest to get your IRL
mouth-watering because these meals look
almost disturbingly good you will
however need specific ingredients to
make certain meals
otherwise you'll be stuck with a piece
of toast for dinner just like in real
life Game Director Hajime Tabata said
sampling local dishes with your crew is
a very important part of the game and
daily boosts are determined by what the
team ate the previous day so that should
help you decide between the salmon
teriyaki skewers and the fixed life
steak fans of Final Fantasy music and I
know there are a lot of you will be
happy to hear that the game lets you go
cruising around listening to old Final
Fantasy soundtrack it looks like you'll
be spending quite a bit of time driving
around in your sweet convertible regalia
in 15 but you won't have to simply enjoy
the sounds of obligatory small talk the
full list of tracks you can listen to
was released earlier this year and it
includes the original soundtracks from
every Final Fantasy game from 1 to 14
plus music from Final Fantasy type-0 and
Dissidia Final Fantasy and Kings glaive
among other offerings sure there's no
500 miles by the Proclaimers on there
but it should still pick up the mood on
those long drives Virtual Reality is the
hot new thing at the moment and final
fantasy 15 is not missing the boat the
Final Fantasy VR experience won't be
available at launch and is likely to
arrive a separate DLC later on it'll be
free to anyone who picks
bass game though so if your wishes to
become part of the Final Fantasy
universe as much as current tech can
allow this should be your thing an early
version of the VR experience lets you
warp around a level as Prompto using a
PS Move controller to shoot your gun at
a big beasty as well as take a road trip
with cindy but we'll have to see what
comes off the floor mode prompt oh isn't
just handy with this ranged attacks
though he's also that guy who always
brings out his camera phone at a party
your power wants to save pictures from
the journey so he'll periodically take
snaps of you and your friends to
presumably look back upon fondly one day
luckily for you you can grab those
pictures and upload them to your social
media things if you like by resting at
an inn allegedly this system will also
connect to the characters actions or
story later on in the game the game
doesn't have a dedicated high-quality
photo mode built in like Uncharted 4 but
this is a nice touch for those of you
into that sort of thing finally we have
chocobos coloured chocobo racing
chocobos and drifting chocobos you name
it we've got it the fan favorite
gigantic bird buddies are back and can
be rented out as states to take you
around the world of yours you're also
able to snag a wild one while not as
fast as your car chocobos are chock full
of personality they can jump high glide
- swim and even drift okay so maybe they
are a bit like your car feeding your
chocobo different things will
temporarily change its stats as will
taking it to camp
if you're feeling competitive you can
compete in races with a birdie or if
you're feeling creative but you can
customize its coat color name and medals
for being a really good chocobo that's
just a selection of some of the cool
things we've found to do but do let me
know what you're keen to get up to in
the game and I will see you again soon
[Music]